well this is truly iconic
I have to tell you yesterday I was in
this weird
Kovach funk I think a lot of us go
through these motions but I was in this
funk I got sent a copy of the book and I
went in sat in the park and read it
there it is Trixie and conscious guide
to modern womanhood and literally this
book put me in a new space so thank you
for that
where did the idea to do a book like
this come from this book it was my
grandma's it was a textbook from a high
school called teen guide to home making
I used to read this and it was crazy
because it was for young women to learn
how to like what to do when a boy calls
on you and like how to make a jell-o
salad and Mike the advice was always so
weird and sexist that energy was like
that's what we should write about like a
modern sort of like helpful information
that's you know a little bit coded and
like what's exaggeration and what's a
dark truth from our reality yeah it's
crazy because you were in studio with me
exactly one year ago this week so this
is a one-year anniversary and you've
mentioned that you were working on this
book so these things take a long time
yes they do Bob yeah yeah it is very
common for me to say that I'm working on
something like I'm like oh I'm doing
this I'm doing that when I've never
started to have no intention of starting
it's a very involved process and also
I'm I was personally terrified by it's
like unchanged ability you know like you
do a live show you can tweak it didn't
change it you just do something
completely different one night and get
sick of it
this is eight this is always gonna be
the same but the celebrity endorsements
have been so glowing you know yeah I saw
my me was actually wanted to buy it and
make a film yeah yeah where you know
it's in negotiation right now because
her production company is under fire for
does that another thing but yeah it's a
it's a very competitive competitive
marketplace out there she will be
playing both roles it's free Eddie
Murphy like yeah very Norbit Norbit big
nor
energy one of my favorite chapters in
the book was the chapter on hands
scientists have estimated that the
average woman aged 18 to 40 who spend
approximately six hours of each day in a
state of mild to severe anxiety about
what to do with her hair and the
question that I asked myself all the
time
should I get bangs yes as a model
actress singer and heiress to summer's
eve I am curious
should I get bangs and if so should I
get like the old-school Justin Bieber or
like the Gale weathers and scream three
bangs
what's the here's the thing but it's
it's it's such it's that question is so
uncomplicated now because of that the
advent of the clip-on Bank T the only
question you should be asking yourself
now is why haven't I bought things yeah
if the Gale weathers and it's also the
sarah michelle gellar season three of
buffy baby bangs the baby baby baby
bangs which is a great drag thing and
Trixie you get a chapter on makeup I
don't want to make sure I get this right
because this actually struck a chord
with me you said you found that people
were more interested in skin camouflage
in skincare and that is probably why I
look like an ashtray that talks so well
unless you're a tired old show hag like
us most people their relationship with
skin makeup should be less complicated
than they think like as much of your
real skin should show as possible if you
know you got a remove makeup safely you
gotta wash it you gotta tone it you got
to moisturize it now tell you something
Delos it's interesting because even
though I've you know I've covered this
book with her and I'm I'm I get to
benefit directly from all of her makeup
wisdom do I use it do I apply it in my
life absolutely no idea well you also
love to use Dawn dish soap which is what
they use to clean oil off baby ducklings
mama if it's good for a baby bird in an
oil spill it's good enough for me
you mentioned different Queens
throughout the book you mentioned you
know loving ben de la cremes personal
style you mention violet chachki just
keeps getting better and better
yeah yeah well honest too and
critical of some other Queens on EB I
know that this is in the book yet or
will they just find it no no nobody
knows nobody knows and they'll just find
out endo and and I'm I guarantee you
that it will turn into a beef Oh it'll
be something I hear about in three years
oh are you kidding drag queens will stay
mad but not confront their feelings so
and I also guarantee you they won't read
the actual text that just take the word
up whoever standards brought it to their
attention on Twitter but also look at us
react and tell me how you could be at
all hearing of what us gutter bucket
monster pieces that think of you or your
poncho we are not role models we are not
good people
we're not life coaches no so like I
don't think our opinion of anybody's
drying even violet if we give her a
compliment she should be like why do I
care what you people think of me like I
know what you both have alone and what
you have together is really something
special
I'm not in a position to tell anybody
what to do which is why I that's why I'm
sitting right here telling you what to
do we've seen your friendships ups and
downs and all around
what do you each love about having this
partnership I like that she offers a
very um she offers are very warm
forgiving and sturdy tether to a real
plane of reality that is enjoyable to
co-exist Maria you're only tether to
reality to be honest together in a short
amount of time we have reached pretty
high highs as a friendship and pretty
deep lows as a friendship I think that
when people do Espie boys tell us like
I'm me and my friend of the trick scene
Conte I want a friendship like yours the
only thing you should aspire to in this
friendship is a mutual understanding of
one another yeah yeah like yeah yeah yes
like we both love a lot of alone time
and that's where we thrive yeah and then
the phone rings and we have a work
commitment together and we get
to nourish your friendship on the clock
okay something I do like about her too
is I'm the I mean I'm capitalist Barbie
do you and I mean like yeah I'm very
serious and businessí and she sometimes
reminds me that it's nice to step
outside and take a smoke break
spiritually you know yeah as a Canadian
boy
Canada's drag race just premiered it is
very chaotic are either of you watching
it yes is there a queen that you are
loving right now Jimbo
yeah Jimbo it's all about Jimbo I really
enjoyed all the entrances that I was
hooked
from the big ten seconds I'm Ilona and
I'm a in if they seem to be having fun
and also taking the piss out of the
format which is so necessary after 14
seasons or whatever people used to enter
the workroom because they have to enter
the workroom and now it's like you know
which is which is a whole whole
different energy that will say this to
it this is not a read to anybody drag me
sis without a RuPaul there really
reminds you how much RuPaul does on her
show you know yeah nephew ah to read to
any of the hosts know all the presence
is so like wow how much do we really
take RuPaul for granted on every single
episode yeah because she is in wind
outside waiting you know anybody's been
on this show in America knows that she
is terrifying
you know maybe she doesn't stay
terrifying but they're initially there
Canadians are too nice they're like we
can't have that over here yeah
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos